[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in Chris Collinsworth football
night in America Sunday Night Football
are you following all of this stuff
Chris with Caleb Williams what's going
on what he wants and what's true and
what's not
true uh we got to unmute you
Chris is that us that Marvin
oh all right we'll figure this out with
uh your setup was gorgeous it was it was
thought blowing nicely thank you thank
you I've been doing this a long time
yeah PA going back to the Caleb Williams
story the other sports Outlets this week
and I use media Outlets air quoting
they're not putting it in the same
perspective Mike Florio did that his dad
inquired with agents that is this even
possible you see articles out there cayb
Williams wants a piece of ownership if
he's going to the let's try this again
with Chris Collinsworth Chris what do
you make of all this Caleb Williams talk
well for being on your show I'd like to
have a piece of your show and U you know
I think that would I think we can
arrange that you know the piece I'm
going to give you is fritzy you can have
fritzy fritzy all right I'll I'll take
fritzy full ownership there yeah full
ownersh send him over send him over
we'll go to work with him so what do you
make of the Caleb Williams story um why
not
right I mean you can take a shot at
anything you want and more and more
we're seeing um family members involved
with negotiations at least when it as it
comes to agents and if I heard the story
correctly it was the dad trying to tell
agents that they would like to have a
piece of a team so it didn't make its
way all the way to Caleb's agent as I
heard it asking for it it was the dad
talking to the agents about it and I I
mean I shoot I've been in a few
negotiations myself over the years I you
asked for a lot of things it doesn't
mean you're going to end up with it so I
mean this kid's obviously a special
player he's going to have options that
nobody has ever had before coming out of
college including staying at USC or
going to any other school that he would
like to go to because of the uh the
nature of college football right now so
um I I I think it's going to be
interesting I think in many ways he is
going to be the next or the first real
test case of how far can a great player
in in particular a great quarterback
push the limits of the NFL because
remember you've got the rookie wage
scale you've got a lot of things to
where if somebody at USC comes up with
some monster number like why would he
not stay and and I've always thought the
one possible competitor to the NFL
would be college football because you've
got that core base of fans built into it
I think as the SEC and and the Big 10
sort of take over the universe we're
going to see almost an AFC and NFC kind
of rivalry and we know historically uh
how that had gone but is there a case I
I can make a case that Caleb Williams
value to
USC is really a lot bigger than what
he's getting being paid because I I I
was on the radio show one time and I
said something about I'll bet you the
amount of money the University of
Kentucky gets when they win a National
Championship not to the college not to
the sports fund but to the General
University fun is probably double when
they win the national championship in
basketball for three hours on the radio
on WLW Radio in Cincinnati I was told
what a complete idiot that I was how
stupid I was I was so beat down Dan I
really did I believed him and it turned
out they were right it wasn't twice as
much it was five times as much and so
now if you take that and Caleb Williams
is stirring the pot and they're getting
all these rich Alum from USC coming in
the PT are they making an extra hundred
million do well if they are can we give
him 20 million of it well if we do does
that keep them in college you know
there's there's situations here that we
have haven't even discussed yet that are
going to be fun to watch we're talking
to Chris Collinsworth full introduction
the former Bengals wide receiver
majority owner of Pro Football Focus and
uh he'll be on the call with Mike too
that'll be Sunday night Dolphins Eagles
820 Eastern on NBC and peacock I'll give
you Tua or I'll give you Jaylen Herz you
got to pick between the
two wow which offense do I get to
run you're starting your team there's no
offense
yet yeah
um I I I think I think I might take Mike
McDaniel you know I I mean so so here's
here's one of the things a defensive
coordinator in the league said to me
about Tua said that he thinks he's the
next Drew Breeze because he his ability
to read things so quickly and they're
playing in that West Coast offense and
he's always been a footwork guy the
thing I loved about him coming out of
Alabama and everybody always wants to
talk about arm strength and it's so
overdone I mean you have to have a
certain level of arm strength in order
to play in this league he has that but
then it's the ability to process quickly
like Brock p is doing in San Francisco
in the same offense process quickly and
throw the ball to Windows you're not
throwing it to a guy he is is not out
there throwing it to Jaylen Wadd he is
throwing it to a 5x5 window on that deep
in cut and basing it on the footwork
that he has and Tua is one of the best
I've seen coming out and the comparison
to Drew was a was a a pretty good one a
guy who nobody talked about his arm
strength right but his ability to
process get the ball out of his hand
throw it in the right window anticipate
throws all those kinds of things so I do
think that Tu a while maybe if he were
in Buffalo would not be what Josh Allen
is you know because you've got to have
the huge arm and a big hand and bad
weather and all those kinds of things
but playing in Miami playing in great
weather and playing in this style of
offense I'll take Drew Brees all day in
that style and I think that's that's the
fit and in Philadelphia you know you've
got a team that's built around their
offensive line and their ability to run
the football and we're going to see
because Miami struggled a little bit
against Carolina trying to to you know
run the football there or stop the run
there so this this style of offense this
run first approach in Philadelphia that
as soon as you start playing the Run
they've got Devonte Smith on the outside
and AJ Brown now you got those guys
oneon-one that's a headache that's a
problem out there so I the quarterbacks
are where they should be I don't know
you flip-flop these two quarterbacks and
it makes much
sense if Brock pie is is an MVP
candidate why is Jared gof not one it's
a great question you know I think that
we saw them beat Kansas City uh on
opening night and there's something
about this team and it goes back to a
season ago I mean they won what was it
eight out of their last 10 something
like that and then jump out to the start
that they are here so this is a team now
that is playing I I I think the hard
part for most people to wrap their head
around is that if he were really that
good of a player why isn't he still in
LA right you know and I mean it's it's
not like Sean doesn't know what he's
doing out there so um you know I I
that's probably the answer but we're a
long way to go I mean these seasons are
so long I I feel like I've been calling
a game every week now for the last six
years and we're not even to the halfway
point here so you know everybody always
says well who you think he's going to
win the Super Bowl and who's going to do
that like tell me who's playing in
January right tell me what lineup looks
like in January and I'll tell you which
team it is that I like because it's such
a war of attrition you never know who's
still going to be standing at the end of
the season we saw just taking out Lane
Johnson for Philadelphia had a major
impact on that game the other day the
right tackle so you know a lot of these
guys are people that you know and that
you know well but so many times it's the
offensive and defensive line which
Philadelphia every year they're drafting
an offensive or a defensive lineman
right they're going to try and win in
the trenches down there and they got
away with a second round pick at
quarterback who ends up being up you
know playing one of the great games
we've seen in Super Bowl history except
for one play uh speaking of the trenches
it feels like competition committee
looking at that brotherly shove the uh
you know the tush push man it feels like
it's too predictable almost like extra
points and that they may want to take it
away uh where do you where do what do
you think the future is of that play
I I love that play I I hope they never
take that play away the reason I love
the play is an former offensive guy
there's nothing better than walking up
to the line of scrimmage and basically
telling the defense we are running right
there right there and you can't stop it
Boomer asias in one time we're playing
the Buffalo Bills I want to say I think
it was in the AFC Championship game and
um and he goes up to the line of
scrimmage and he starts pointing at
Bruce Smith over Anthony Munoz and he
goes hey Bruce Bruce we're running right
there Anthony Munoz is the greatest
player in the world we're running right
there and we're scoring a touchdown and
Anthony you can see him on the film he's
like he's like waving you know he's like
he's like shut up like what are you
doing and he comes he comes over to me
on the sideline and he goes Chris Chris
you got to get Boomer to shut up he's
just pissing off you know Bruce over
there I'm like I don't care I'm just
trying to talk him into throw me the
ball I don't care what he does with
Bruce Smith over there are you crazy U
what what's the fan base that gets the
most upset at you
Cincinnati you picked him to win the
Super Bowl this year I know I know as
soon as I did they started losing games
it's unbelievable but yeah I mean I had
one lady one time she uh so I was in a
doctor's office and I go in and and so
she's mad at me I can tell she's mad at
me and I was like oh man I must have
forgot to you know pay or you know do
the paperwork or something whatever they
get mad at you in doctor's offices for
and I was like okay I said well you know
what's up here what what's the problem
and she goes I listened to the game the
other night they scored four touchdowns
in that game and you didn't say who day
after one single one of them I'm like go
um yeah no I can't do that I'm not
allowed to say but they expect me to
root for the Bengals so when I got the
Super Bowl the year that the Bengals
were in it I was like oh this is death
here there's no way either I'm going to
be a complete Homer in the eyes of the
Rams Fans or I'm gonna be a complete
jerk in the eyes of the Bengals fans I
mean it was remember the old TV show
Dragnet you know just the facts ma'am I
was I was just the facts ma'am in in in
that Super Bowl Trevor Lawrence poll
question Satan give Chris the wording on
that see where Chris uh false on
it the wording is Dan Trevor Lawrence is
dot dot dot a top 10 quarterback or
somewhat
disappointing
um I'm gon to say a top 10 quarterback I
I I I I I don't know that I would have
said that
originally um but I do think that Doug
Peterson has had an impact on him um
he's better than what he was and you
know it's it's so funny that
that these guys that get drafted high
right they get multiple opportunities I
mean think it think if if Trevor
Lawrence were a fifth round pick that
happened to get to play right in his
first year and that was all we saw we
saw one year he was a fifth round pick
and that was it we would have
collectively I think gone he doesn't
have it right he doesn't have it and
they would have mov moved on and he
would have been one of those second
string guys that bounce from Team to
team until he's out of football but when
they're the first overall
pick you've seen it somewhere and you
just keep you just keep giv them the
ball or you change coaches or you do
like the belief is that he's going to
get there and I always wonder how many
guys would have if they would have been
given the three or the fouryear window
of opportunity could have worked their
way out of it and become something you
know but if you're even a second round
draft pick or a late first round draft
pick it seems like you get seven eight
nine games and it's you're not making
magic out there they're they're turning
the page so I I think that I there's
enough of an upward trajectory here to
where I think you go yeah that if I only
got to take the top 10 guys and I got
one of those 10 and he were one of the
10 would I take him yes I would good to
talk to you Chris thanks for joining us
have fun on Sunday night thank you Dan
good to see anybody that's Chris Collins
worth football night in America he'll be
there with Mike too 820 Eastern it'll be
the Eagles and the Dolphins